oh it's gotta be me
you saw it those stones that the Thanos
they must them man here could
survive how do we know you will we don't
but the radiations mostly gamma it's
like I was made for this
good to go yeah
let's do it you remember everyone Thanos
snapped away five years ago we're just
bringing them back to now today don't
change anything from the last five years
good
everybody comes up
take it all the way Bruce are you okay
oh me banner
okay okay
hi everybody its charlie surprise
surprise the producers in the writers of
avengers endgame revealed a big red hulk
scene that didn't make it into the final
cut of the movies so we'll break it down
there's a new round of that Avengers
endgame blu-ray giveaway - all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave your biggest Marvel phase 4 theory
on the video I'll name a new winner at
the end of this everybody's been asking
about Red Hulk ever since we got
Avengers infinity war are we gonna see
Thunderbolt Ross ever become Red Hulk
will the Red Hulk scene that the
producers and the writers told us about
is very different from people's
expectations it would have been very
different from Red Hulk in the comics
and the reason why it didn't make it
into the movie is very similar to the
reason why they coat the grey Hulk scene
out of Avengers age of Ultron which I'll
explain if you guys don't know the grey
Hulk story it's also pretty fascinating
but during avengers endgame what was
originally going to happen in this scene
here that I put at the beginning of the
video where Hulk is wielding the
Infinity Gauntlet is that when Iron Man
assembles his nano Infinity Gauntlet
which is the official name that Marvel
is giving it the nano gauntlet because
it's made with Iron Man's nanotechnology
what happens is that Hulk detects the
intense cosmic energy in gamma radiation
coming off of the combined Infinity
stones and thinks that it's similar to
the gamma that irradiated him giving him
his Hulk powers originally so when he
puts the Infinity Gauntlet on in the
theatrical cut you can see the same
thing happening to him that happened to
Thanos when Thanos put the mine stone in
the gauntlet and combined all six you
see that giant arc of cosmic and gamma
energy arcing across their bodies and
the reason they can soak that damage is
because they're so powerful like when
Thanos added one stone at a time you see
one arc of cosmic and gamma energy run
up his body when he added the second
stone you see two arcs go up and so on
and so forth the energy starts to stack
so it's not like you have six times that
energy running up you it grows
exponentially so that's why it
normal humans that haven't been in
ants like Captain America the reason why
Captain America has a lot of people
wonder didn't wear the Infinity Gauntlet
is because Hulk was standing there and
he's way more powerful so if Hulk hadn't
been there if it had just been Captain
America and Iron Man then it would have
been Captain America to wield the
gauntlet and snap everyone back but what
happened in the original version of this
scene where Hulk is snapping everyone
back is that when he put the Infinity
Gauntlet on the combined gamma and
cosmic energy from the gauntlet
interacted with his own gamma energy in
the catalytic reaction turned him into
Red Hulk instead of just destroying his
arm the main reason why the writers
revealed that that didn't make it into
the final cut of the film's because one
it was really confusing it was a big
change to the comics and everybody kind
of been asking for Red Hulk at some
point because Thunderbolt Ross is still
alive even though he had been snapped in
that five-year time jump that's why you
never saw him at the beginning of the
movie he only appears at the funeral at
the end because he'd been snapped during
that big five-year time jump that's kind
of the reason why they didn't do grey
Hulk during Avengers age of Ultron the
story that Joss Whedon told about grey
Hulk because obviously the grey Hulk in
the comics is Joe fix-it and it's very
different from what Joss Whedon was
talking about when he was talking about
his gray Hulk scene what was supposed to
happen is that Scarlet Witch when she
messes with his mind and he Hulk's out
she messes with him so much that he's
supposed to go world breaker Hulk mad
the way Joss Whedon talked about it is
that what happens if the Hulk were
already the Hulk and then Hulk's out on
top of that what's the Hulk's version of
the Hulk when they were editing this big
fight scene with Ironman he had the
visual effects artist push his color
crazier and crazier but what happened is
is that he started to look gray so Joss
Whedon is like oh okay this is starting
to turn into a grey Hulk scene so after
a while he just decided that it got too
confusing for test audiences they would
have needed to have a whole separate
scene explaining who this different
color this different version of the Hulk
is so that's why he pulled way back on
it effectively getting rid of the grey
Hulk stuff during the movie and then
went to Kevin Feige while they were
still working on the film and said
here's a big twist a grey Hulk twist
that you can always use in a future
movie if you want so it's basically the
same situation with Red Hulk in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe a big twist
that they can always use in Marvel phase
four or Marvel phase five if they want
to because Mark Ruffalo is still around
they
still have that big deal with universal
that's making it hard for them to
release a solo hold film so there will
still be Hulk stuff going on during
Marvel phase four and Marvel phase 5 but
there are a couple big twists that they
haven't used yet but they haven't made
any promise that it would be the
Thunderbolt Ross version of Red Hulk
there's just an idea that a Red Hulk
might pop up at some point if you're not
familiar with where the Red Hulk and the
comics came from it's actually right out
of World War Hulk I know everybody wants
world breaker Hulk within the Marvel
Cinematic Universe when are we gonna get
world breaker Hulk the funny thing is is
the comic book world breaker Hulk was
used to create comic book Red Hulk
so during World War Hulk Hulk goes full
world breaker turns on all his former
friends Iron Man and the other heroes
developed a last-ditch way to depower
him using earth satellites getting rid
of all this cosmic and gamma energy that
was inside of him while this was going
on
the intelligencia which is MODOK and a
bunch of the other smartest villains in
the Marvel comic book universe got
together and developed a way to hack
Iron Man's special technology that he
was going to use on the Hulk they knew
that they needed a weapon that they
could control that could fight people
like the Hulk and the other heroes they
knew it was just gonna be a matter of
time before they came back for them to
stop them from trying to take over the
world so in the middle of World War Hulk
while Hulk is fighting the Sentry to a
standstill
Iron Man activates his anti Hulk weapon
protocol and because it's happening in
such a panic he doesn't have time to
double check the math or make sure that
everything's working correctly he just
fires the weapon off the weapon is meant
to depower him back into banner form so
that they can actually deal with him but
while this is happening MODOK who has
hacked this technology siphons off all
that cosmic and gamma energy and puts it
into another person creating the Red
Hulk that person just happened to be the
resurrected body of Thunderbolt Ross who
was working with the intelligencia so
when he started out in the comics Red
Hulk was this big villain he was a big
asshole that everybody wanted to get rid
of eventually he regains his sanity and
turns into more of an antihero working
with some of the more morally Grey's
superheroes he goes on a bunch of cosmic
adventures he does a bunch of crazy
things just recently because of absolute
carnage if you guys haven't been reading
that story arc they just the
character off carnage
came for him because at one time he had
a symbiote that's a little different
story because they're getting ready to
start shooting the venom sequel the
venom versus carnage movie I will talk
about more venom and carnage absolute
carnage stuff if it's relevant to what's
going on during the movie but leave all
your video requests in the comments
below and let me know in the comments if
they do Red Hulk because William Hurt is
getting up there in years if he's not
able to come back and play the actual
Red Hulk in like five or six years what
would you want them to do with that
character because I know everybody wants
to see him at some point we're all
waiting on she-hulk Amadeus Cho pretty
much any other version of the Hulk you
could think of because I mean obviously
they're gonna keep making Marvel movies
till the heat death of the universe so
at some point we will see these
characters and I'm sure eventually
Marvel will find a way to get the rest
of the rights back from Universal so
that they can do another hulk solo film
at some point but that might not happen
till way down the road after Mark
Ruffalo isn't playing the character
anymore so rooting speculation that
would just wind up being a different
version of that character but motion
capture technology is getting so perfect
that Mark Ruffalo could probably play
the Hulk for another ten years without
any big problems I'm working on
spider-man far from home deleted scenes
that video should post pretty soon
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big Marvel video cinema
dawg Oh to please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your
details
everybody click here for my venom 2
teaser video venom vs carnage and click
here for my video about Amazon's the
boys series basically dark Justice
League thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight!